i feel like the news made things very
confusing the news started becoming like
not information and a lot of people got
extremely scared and didn't know who to
believe anymore well here you go you
want the answer to the news yeah jesse
has it yeah i'd like a you know i
wouldn't mind a dose of it man because
that's where i feel like a lot of bad
information started downfall of the news
came with the show 60 minutes
now you guys are all going to sit and do
no i like i i i how could you 60 minutes
that's an award-winning investigative
reporting show which it is and it's a
great show
it was a great show still is probably a
great show
but 60 minutes was the downfall of the
american media was that when they
started editorializing it
prior to 60 minutes
all the news lost money
and
they made up for it in the entertainment
division and that was a standard rule
the news is to educate the news is to do
this the news don't make money it's to
inform
along came the show 60 minutes it shot
the number one
in the ratings the bean counter's eyes
got big and they went you mean we can
make money off the news yeah that's what
60 minutes caused
making profit off the news
then it became about ratings
rather than informing
now the news is nothing but
entertainment right
so that's there to get ratings points
it's there to make money for advertisers
where in the days of walter cronkite
back when i
was younger than you
the news lost money you want the show
that was so ahead of its time the movie
that it's scary today for me to watch it
watch the show network yeah with faye
dunaway
uh
william holden i've seen that it's good
and peter finch won the academy award
for playing howard beale because he just
got so real and that's and it changed
everything no that's where it became
entertainment remember they brought
faith done away in from entertainment
yes to get the rabies
this was done before it ever happened to
the news yeah they call up to her desk
and she's like
let him go i knew 60 minutes it changed
it yeah
so that movie whoever wrote the script
or whatever
was was looking into the future and had
their thumb right on the button wow
because that's what our media or our
news has turned into the movie network
so then it's all about ratings points
now guys it ain't about making you
smarter or giving you information it's
about tiddly look at right now
what's the big news out there right now
another missing white girl yeah
now if that girl was black you think
they'd be all that front page
stories every night if there was a lot
of black people don't go hiking really
though but maybe probably not maybe not
you know maybe not black girls disappear
every day yeah and you don't see though
where they i saw
all people disappear every day probably
but why is it that they pick out
the kids right there's these cute
looking little guys
yeah yeah the cute little and don't get
me wrong it's a tragedy it's horrifying
whatever happened to her don't get me
wrong on that no totally
the media's coverage of it it's okay
when i was gonna do the show for msnbc
everything comes down from on high yeah
they tell you what they're like hannity
and these guys they get told what to
talk about totally yeah you know i
fought them you know what they sent me
every day lacey peterson what and i said
that's a tragedy but there's 10 000
murders a year why is this one
exceptional and why should people in
minnesota or in the east coast care
about a murder that took place out in
california yeah yes we feel sad lacey
was murdered
like i feel sad that anybody else gets
murdered
but why would i on a national tv show
give five minutes of the show's time
covering a murder that affects
that when you have ten thousand of them
a year yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one